one in four u.s hospitals are now
reporting critical staff shortages as
coven 19 patients fill up rooms this
missouri hospital is out of nurses
housekeepers and beds every place is
full and we're back where we started
where everybody's looking all over the
country for beds from small towns in
missouri to big cities the story is the
same
luminous community medical center just
outside washington d.c has seen a 925
percent increase in covert 19 cases
since thanksgiving that's what hurts the
most because the erosion of these care
teams
is invariably going to lead to an
erosion of health care quality
more than 120 thousand americans are
currently hospitalized with covet 19 the
highest level in a year on friday close
to 1800 died from the virus the phone
calls to their families are the hardest
part for those on the front lines i'm so
sorry to be calling you like this i'm
sorry i'm sorry for what you're going
through
more than 70 percent of those
hospitalized with the virus are
unvaccinated including 63-year-old ned
epperson if i had to do it all over
again i wouldn't think twice
take the shot
just 62 percent of americans are fully
vaccinated the cdc is urging
unvaccinated adults to get protected as
many are infecting children under the
age of five pediatric hospitalizations
are at their highest level since the
pandemic began
parents are feeling the strain we might
even just keep our 13 year old out of
class and our 4 year old out of the
preschool
most likely next week because it's just
not worth taking a chance essential
workers are being hard hit too about 20
percent of new york city police officers
are out sick with covet 19 more than 1
000 police officers firefighters and
paramedics in los angeles too those
whose jobs are to protect are unable to
protect themselves from this quick
spreading virus
jennifer johnson global news washington